in this episode of cloud performance
atlas I helped some toy makers with
their boot times will performance be the
hot toy this holiday season stay tuned
to find out capital fun is an IOT toy
developer who has been converting over
portions of their architecture to
serverless systems however as their
google cloud functions uses didn't scale
to meet demand as fast as they wanted
they quickly pinned cold boot time as
the culprit and reached out to us to see
how they could improve it which totally
makes sense I even though GCF is
considered a serverless architecture you
still have to be aware that there are
some cold boot time overhead as new
instances are spun up now most of the
time your function will already be
running an instance and will be ready to
handle future triggers as fast as
possible however your functions might be
in a cold state because number one your
function has been deployed but not
triggered yet or number two your
function has been idle long enough that
it was recycled for resources or number
three your function is auto-scaling to
handle capacity and creating a new
instance in any of these cases your code
isn't currently running and the next
trigger event will spin up a new
instance now when it comes to GCF the
number one contributor to slow cold boot
performance is dependencies when a
module boots no Jess resolves all the
require calls from the entry point using
synchronous i/o which can take a
significant amount of time if the number
of dependencies are large or if the
content itself requires a lot of linking
so when I saw that there's GCF module
had 50 dependencies well we knew where
to focus our efforts as a first step we
worked with their tech team to trim out
any dependencies that might not be
needed this includes areas where they
might be using one function from a
library but including the entire library
so after a lot of negotiation digging
and spaghetti code clinging we were able
to get down to eight packages resulting
in a 2x performance in cold boot time
which was good but there was still work
to do next up we looked at what
dependency versions their functions were
actually using more popular versions of
a package are most likely already stored
in gcf's dependency cache
meaning that importing and resolving can
be done much quicker so once we unified
of capital funds dependencies to use the
same versions that were more likely to
be used in the cache we saw another nice
performance boost finally digging
through the node.js code we decided to
set up lazy loading of core requirements
rather than having them all occur in
cold boot phase this allowed us to
require only what's needed at the start
and then switch to an async version of
the require keyword later for specific
request handling bringing down the cold
boot times even further with these small
changes we saw a 10x improvement in
capital funds called boot time which
isn't bad for a day's work and you want
to know more about the changes check out
the article in the description below and
don't forget to check out the rest of
our cloud performance Atlas content
because when it comes to performance
every millisecond counts